>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Lee Ann Potter: How
many of you like cats?
Okay, now we're getting somewhere.
Okay, how many of you
like chocolate?
I knew that one, I'm telling you.
How many of you know
where California is?
Okay. How many of you have ever --
okay, this is a really
important one.
How many of you have ever
gone to your school library
or public library, and --
and come home with a stack
of books at least this big.
[ Kids Chattering, Yelling ]
All right, see I knew it.
See, I figured that with
all of those questions,
I would come up with at
least one where I could say,
you guys all have something
in common
with our very special guest today.
>> Jeanne Walker Harvey: Wow.
That is wonderful.
>> Lee Ann Potter: So, Jeanne is
here to visit with us this morning
about her new book about Mya Lin.
And not only has Jeanne
written a book about Mya Lin,
but she's also written books about
other artists, and about animals.
So, the floor is yours.
>> Jeanne Walker Harvey: Great.
Thank you.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Thank
you so much for being here.
>> Jeanne Walker Harvey:
Appreciate that was really nice.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
[inaudible] Thank you.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
So, welcome everyone.
I can't tell you how
excited I am to be here,
I could hardly sleep last
night, I was so excited.
The Library of Congress,
that's like, the best library.
So, I live across the
country in California.
And I flew across last night, and
my cat, her name is Ally, she said,
"Will you please be sure
to say hello to everyone?"
So, will you please
say hello back to Ally
when I count to three really loudly?
Her name's Ally.
One, two, three.
>> Hello, Ally!
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Hello, Ally!
Oh, wonderful, because she gets
a little jealous because most
of the time when I'm writing
she's sitting on my lap.
So, I told her she couldn't be part
of the slide show though, so --
but I will tell her you said hello.
So, anyways, what I'm going to
tell you today is a little bit
of my background of
why I'm a writer.
What inspired me, and
why I wrote this book?
What inspired me to write the book,
and I want to hear about your ideas
after I read the book too.
so, I'm just going to run through
a few things about my background.
So, that's me with my grandmother,
and she got me excited
about writing.
I would write a little bit
of a story, mail it to her,
and she would add to the story,
and then she'd mail it back to me,
so we'd make long stories together.
And when I was in first
grade I moved to California
to Illinois right near Disneyland.
I know, so I got to go to
Disneyland, and that made me think
about stories all about those Disney
characters, and that magic castle.
And the Matterhorn, and all the --
I just made my imagination,
my creativity went wild.
There I am with my mom
when I'm there in --
I think I was probably second
grade then in that photo,
looking out at Disneyland.
And what I loved, and my mom taught
me to love is everything modern.
Raise your hand if you
know what modern means?
Yes?
What do you think modern -- it's
kind of a wild word isn't it?
Think about it.
Do yo want to think about it?
>> Design.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Design,
yeah, modern design, yes?
>> I think it means normal?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Normal, okay.
Yeah.
>> I think it means
like, when you're good?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Okay,
I love all these ideas.
Modern is when -- is part of
design and it is sort of a normal,
because it's what current,
what's new ideas.
So, think modern as
like, new -- new ideas.
So, when -- so, there's
my dad at work,
and he had very modern
furniture for the time.
And that big painting
behind him, my mom painted,
because she loved to
paint modern art.
So, that's where I started
learning about modern art,
and I went to the Museum
of Art in Los Angeles.
That was my library that I
went to, and as she was saying,
I would come home with
a big stack of books.
And my mom would come home with
a big, heavy stack of books,
because that would be art books,
she'd get really big art books,
and I'd go to more museums.
Well, fast-forward to when I was
in college, so, I was in college
in California over where the star
is, and I read a newspaper article,
a press clipping that said someone
from across the country the same age
as I was, and her name is --
Can you say that name?
Mya Lin?
>> Mya Lin.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Mya Lin.
So, she won a contest, and so, she
was just my age, she was a senior
in college, and she won a contest
to design the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial right here
in Washington D.C. And I
thought, well, that is so cool,
I want to learn more about that.
So, there's a photo of her, and
she's holding the design that she --
she made a model, and she mailed
this in, and she won this contest.
And look at that, that's right
here, this is from the Library
of Congress, this is right here.
It's so cool, so cool, the original
one is right here in this building.
So, she had designed --
has anyone been there?
Does that ring a bell?
Does that -- do you recognize that?
Maybe you've been there,
maybe you will go there.
So, she -- so, here
is more photos of it.
So, she, for this contest needed to
include all the names of soldiers
who had died during the Vietnam War.
So, the whole wall is covered
with names, it's a very powerful,
very touching place to visit.
And here she is very excited
that she won this design contest,
but people all didn't
like the design.
So, there she is also at a
hearing right here in -- the --
in Congress, right
across the street.
And they -- she looks
pretty serious, doesn't she,
because people were saying,
"Mm, I don't think we
like the design that you did."
But, she said, no, it's a really
important way to show how we care
for our soldiers who have fallen.
So, she kept with her ideas, and so
I thought, I want to write a book
about her, because
she's so interesting,
and such a strong person.
So, I read about her, I
watched videos about her,
I listened to her talk on the
-- yeah, music would be good.
I listened to music of the
time, that's a good idea,
that gives you an idea,
a lot of the music.
And so, that's her as a little
girl, her parents came from China,
so there's her parents,
and they were both teachers
in -- of art and poetry.
So, she lived in a house
with lots of art and music.
We already talked beforehand, a
lot of you like music and art too.
And that's her father, you can see
he did interesting things with clay.
Has anyone made anything
with clay before?
Yeah, it's a nice feeling isn't
it, you sort of design things.
And so, she watched her father
making clay, and she said,
"That really" -- that
idea stayed with her,
the idea of how you
create something.
It's just a big blob of clay, but
then you create something beautiful
with your hands, and that's
the house where she lived.
And you can see there's
trees around it, and that --
she really loves nature, and she
still -- she lives in New York City,
and right now she's doing lots of
projects involving the environment,
because she cares so
much about nature.
So, what I did is I
started researching,
learning, reading books.
And these are some of the books, you
can see lots of books, and -- oh!
>> There's Ally.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Did she
sneak herself into my slideshow?
That little sneaky kitty, do any
of you have sneaky animals at home?
>> No.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah.
Yeah. Okay, so this is my cat
Ally, I think she looks very happy
that you all said hello
earlier, that was very nice.
>> Hello, Ally.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: So, you can
see what she does, when I'm trying
to work she gets right in-between
me and the laptop, so I can't type,
and she says, "I need to be petted."
So, anyway, she does help me a lot,
and what she was really excited
to learn was Mya Lin, she --
her cat helps her work too.
So, there's Mya Lin, the book
that I'm going to read to you
and her cat, and her cat's
sitting right on her paper,
it's just like she does with me.
So, that -- you can see her.
So, Mya Lin is what we
call an architect artist.
So, an architect's someone
who builds buildings,
and then, but also makes art.
So, here I wrote the words, and
have any of you written something,
your teacher gives it back to you,
and says -- with some changes on it?
Yeah. So, that's what that is,
and that's how we can get our
writing better and better,
because we're asked to do changes.
And then, when the book became
-- was going to become a story,
then we found someone to draw
the pictures, the illustrator.
And her name is Dow
Phumiruk, and here are some
of her pictures that she does.
And there's the book, and
you can see how it's changed.
Yeah, see, this is
the way it is now,
but first she drew the
cover in a different way.
Oh, you know what?
That's inside the story,
yes, it is inside,
and that where the yellow square
is, if you look really carefully
in your book, and I get to be in it.
So, she put me in the
book, isn't that nice?
>> Why did she put you in the book?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: She
was just being nice, she said,
"I think I should put you
in the book as a visitor
at the memorial", so
that was very nice.
And then, she wrote me
a letter, and My Lin --
>> Can you read it?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah,
I'm going to read it right now.
And Mya Lin wrote me a letter, and
said, "I really like your book.
I like your words, and
I like your pictures",
and that me feel very good, because
I had tried -- it's about her life.
If someone wrote a book about
you, you'd want to be sure
that it was what you liked.
Yeah, thumbs up, exactly.
So, let's read the book.
Okay. Okay, Mya Lin,
say her name again.
>> Mya Lin.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Thank you.
Artist, architect,
of light and lines,
designer of the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial.
And there's the cover inside, and
there's her house where she grew up.
In the woods by her childhood home,
Mya Lin played with her brother,
and explored and climbed
the many rolling hills,
one she named the Lizard's Back.
On long walks alone, she
searched for birds in the forest,
Mya sat still as a statue.
Can you sit still as a statue?
>> [inaudible]
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Hoping
to tame rabbits, raccoons,
chipmunks, and squirrels.
Aww, she was very quiet.
In her house full of light and
open spaces, Mya read books,
and played chess with her brother.
And with paper and scraps
she built tiny towns.
Her parents had fled China, so
they had left China at a time
when people were told what
to be, and how to think.
Her parents never told Mya
what to be or how to think.
Mya grew up with art, her father was
an artist who made art with clay.
Her mother was a poet
who made art with words.
She watched her father form
a pot from a mound of clay
without plans or drawings.
Mya too thought with her
hands, as well as her mind.
One day when Mya looked at the
patterns of light and lines
on the ceiling of her
college library,
she imagined she would become an
architect who created buildings
with art, science, and math.
While studying overseas, Mya
wondered through countries
and cities gazing at
buildings of all types,
new and old, learning all she could.
In her last year of college,
Mya entered a contest
to design a memorial
to honor soldiers
who died during the Vietnam War.
The contest rules said the memorial
must blend with a park setting,
and include the name of every
soldier who died fighting
or was missing, almost
58,000 names, mm-hmm.
These rules rang true to Mya,
she knew the power of names.
Mya believed that a name brings back
all the memories of a person more
than a photo of a moment in time.
In the glow of the autumn sun,
Mya walked across a field dotted
with trees, the site
of the future memorial.
Through her camera's eye,
she imagined a knife slicing
through open -- the -- a
knife slicing open the earth.
And in her mind, she saw the cut
in the earth healing over time
to a polished edge covered
from top to bottom with names.
An edge that reflected sky,
and grass, and the people
who visited the memorial.
Back at school, Mya sculpted
a model with mashed potatoes.
Yeah, mashed potatoes,
because remember,
she thought with her
hands, and she --
so, she was at dinner and thought,
"Oh, I know what it should be",
and she used the mashed potatoes.
And then, she modeled with clay,
she sketched a soft space of greens
and blues, you can see
right here -- right here.
And before mailing her entry she
put her thoughts into an essay,
right here, she wrote it,
she hand-wrote this essay
explaining about it.
She wrote that her long, polished
wall would be a quiet place
to remember all those
who died during the war.
And a place to be experienced by
walking down and up past names
that seemed to go on forever.
The contest received
so many entries,
enough to fill an airplane
hangar, that's a place
where they store airplanes.
Lots of famous architects
and artists entered,
and the names of the
contestants were hidden
from view, they just had a number.
Right here, she was number 1026,
and behind this poster there
was an envelope with her name,
so they didn't know who it was.
There's the judges looking at all
the posters, you recognize that one?
>> Yeah.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Where is it?
Yeah, right there,
very cool isn't that?
[inhales sharply] Out of 1,421
entries Mya's was design was chosen.
Simple, yet strong, creative
and new, but when they found
out Mya was the winner,
the judges were shocked.
She wasn't famous, she was a
young woman still in school.
Mya was as surprised as the
judges, all was excitement at first,
but then people objected.
Some people didn't like it, some
said the design looked like a bat,
a boomerang, a black gash of shame,
they're angry words stung Mya.
For months, public hearings were
held, and some people wanted
to change the design, Mya
was young, but she was brave,
she didn't back down, right?
Finally, her design was approved,
and Mya worked with a team
of architects and engineers who
devised plans to excavate the land,
to dig it up, and then
build the wall.
The granite, so the stone was
cut, polished, and engraved,
carved with the soldiers' names.
The earth was dug up,
and Mya watched the panel
suspended in space set in place.
And there's the people looking,
and there's -- she put her --
Mya Lin putting her
hand against the names.
The first time Mya
visited the finished wall,
she searched for the name
of the father of a friend.
And when she touched the name, she
cried just as she knew others would.
Thousands came that Veterans Day
to see, to touch, and remember.
Salutes, hands on heart honoring,
and every day since then,
visitors have done the same.
And this Saturday is the 35th
anniversary of that Veterans Day.
So, there'll be lots of
people here, that's right.
The Vietnam's Veteran Memorial was
the first of Mya's many works of art
and architecture, memorial
sculptures, structures
and spaces inside and out.
And each piece is different,
but all share Mya's vision,
she wants people to
be a part of her art.
Look! Read, walk around, sit
by, think about -- mm-hmm.
And just like when she named a hill
the -- do you remember what it was?
The Lizard's Back, Mya names her
projects often words from nature.
Names such as Sounding
Stones, Topo, can you say Topo?
>> Topo.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
That's a fun one, isn't it?
The Wave Field, 10 Degrees
North, and Reading a Garden.
And there she is with her cat, had
to put the cat in there, right?
And after naming a piece, the
final step in shaping her artwork,
Mya Lin, the artist architect
is ready to dream, think again,
and create something new.
And that's the story of Mya Lin.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jean Walker Harvey: So, what
do you remember about Mya Lin?
>> That she had a cat?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: That
she had a cat, exactly, yes.
>> She called hill,
The Lizard's Back.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: She
called the hill where she grew
up The Lizard's Back, yes?
>> And when the people like,
they didn't like her art.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
And what did she do?
When the people didn't like
her art, what did she do?
>> She --
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Did she stand up?
Was she strong?
>> She was strong.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: She
was strong, exactly, good.
Yes? I remember that she -- that
when people didn't like her poster,
she standed up and said,
I'm not going to give up.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Wonderful.
She said -- when people didn't like
her poster and the design on it,
she said, I'm going to stand
up, I'm not going to give up.
Great. Good remembering.
Good.
>> That they -- that they didn't --
that she was in school, and she --
and they can't -- they
couldn't believe that she was
in school and she made that art.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Exactly.
They couldn't believe
it that the winner
of the contest was still in school.
They couldn't believe that,
they were just shocked, yes.
She was so young.
Yes.
>> Her whole family loved art.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Good remembering.
Her whole family loved art.
Her mom was a poet, her
dad made art with clay.
She grew up around art
and it inspired her, yes.
>> I think that she -- had to make
that, because she was learning
about to make it with
mashed potatoes.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Exactly.
So, when she was inspired by
the -- she came up with an idea,
and she said, "Oh, I need to
make it, how should I make it?"
And she used her hands
and made it out of --
>> Mashed potatoes.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Mashed potatoes.
You get to play with food, right.
Yes?
>> When she was surprised that
she win the contest of the thing.
>> Yes, when she won
the contest she was
so surprised just like the judges.
Yes?
>> When she was writing her
grandma, she wrote something,
and then she mailed
it to her grandma.
And then, her grandma
wrote some of it,
and then her grandma
even mailed it back.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
That's lovely.
You remembered what I did as
an author, that I wrote stories
and sent it to my grandmother,
and then she would add
to it, and send it back.
Yes, and that inspired me just
like Mya Lin's parents inspired her
with the art, I was
inspired to do my writing.
Right, very nice.
Yes?
>> She built the soldiers
who died during the war.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Very good.
She built a memorial --
she designed a memorial
that honored the soldiers
during the Vietnam War who died
by having a memorial designed that
was -- included all the names,
which was 57,000 names,
so many people.
So, she was honoring them.
Very nice you remembered this.
Yes?
>> She was watching the
architects build a wall.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Mm-hmm.
She was an artist architect who
designed what they call The Wall,
because it has -- it's the two walls
that come together like a long V.
And it has the names, and people
are -- when you walk by it,
you walk down, and then walk
back up, and you're reflected,
your picture is reflected
on the names.
Yes?
>> She put her hand in
the wall to say the names.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: And
that's nice, and she --
>> And she was crying.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: And she
was crying when she put her name
against the wall where her father
-- her friend's father's name was.
She cried just like she
knew other would cry,
and I cried when I
was there too, mm-hmm.
Yes?
>> You know, when I was a
little kid my grandmother died.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Oh,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Names are very important, that's
a way of remembering people,
that's what she was saying.
We think of everything --
when you think of your name,
or your friend's name, or your
family's name, or your grandmother,
you remember all sorts
of things about them.
That's why Mya Lin thought
the power of the name.
So, do you have any questions
about the book, about writing?
Someone had one about the Library
of Congress before I came
in, will you share that one?
>> I said, what -- how long has
the Library of Congress been here?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: How long has
I would love to know that answer.
>> Lee Ann Potter: I
love that question.
The Library of Congress has existed
since 1800, but this building
that you're in, it's a lot younger.
It's only been here since the 1890s.
It's old, isn't that neat.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Can
you say what the Library
of Congress -- it's the most --
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: To me, it --
>> Lee Ann Potter: Have
you guys been here before?
>> No.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay.
Well, you're going to love this.
So, when you go home today, you
can tell your parents that --
okay, you ready for this?
>> Yes.
>> Lee Ann Potter: The Library
of Congress is the largest
library in the whole world.
So, when you go home, and you
say, "Guess what I did today?"
And your folks are like,
"What'd you do today?"
You say, "I went to the
world's largest library, and" --
I'm serious, you got to do this.
Because those conversations with
your family are the best way
for them to tell you
about their day,
and for you to tell
them about your day.
So, you say, "I went to
the Library of Congress,
the world's largest library today,
and I got to meet an author."
And they'll say, "Oh,
who was that author?"
And you'll say, oh, her
name is Jean Walker Harvey.
And they'll say, "Oh, tell
me about Jean Walker Harvey."
And you'll say, "Well, she
wrote this book about Mya Lin."
And they'll say, "Who's Mya Lin?"
And you guys will tell the whole
story, and your parents will look
at you, and your grandparents
will look, and your brothers
and sisters will look at you, and
your friends and neighbors will look
at you like -- and
they'll be so impressed.
How many of you will do that?
Yes, I know you all will.
Awesome.
>> There were other
questions I think.
>> One time when I was doing
a quiz in my mom's car,
it asked what is the
biggest library,
and I said the Library of Congress.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
You already knew that.
All right.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: That's great.
He already asked someone
about the Library of Congress.
He knew that, that's great.
Yes?
Jean Walker Harvey: Did
you have a question?
Okay.
Jean Walker Harvey: Okay,
we'll come back to you.
Did someone else have a question
about writing books, or -- yes?
>> What book did you
write before -- ?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Oh, which
book did I write before Mya Lin?
Well, that was one
of my animal books.
That came out in last year, and
it's about a Hawaiian monk seal.
Hawaiian monk seal.
So, it was -- she had a fishing
hook caught in her mouth.
I know, I --
>> That's going to hurt.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: That would
-- that's going to hurt a lot,
but they were able to take
it out, and they saved her.
So, that's a really sweet story,
I like animal stories too.
I like art, and I like animals, just
like Mya Lin likes art and nature.
So -- yes?
>> Why do you write books?
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Why do I write books?
Great question.
Jean Walker Harvey: So, I write
books because I love stories.
And I actually love all sorts of
stories, but particularly for me,
I like to write true stories that
inspire us, that we learn things.
I'm so curious, and I get
to then read lots of books
to write my books, so I'm
always wanting to learn more.
But I also think words are really
powerful, words share emotions,
ideas, they describe things.
So, I just think that
-- how many of you -- ?
Let's see again who --
how many like to read?
Great. And how many
of you like to write?
Oh! So, I bet there's some
authors in this group, yes, mm-hmm.
Yes? Did you have a -- ?
Oh, you were stretching.
Yes?
>> [inaudible]
>> There was a robbery,
and then the --
one of the best friends they
found out who was the robber,
it was their other best friend.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: That
seems like a sad story, but it --
that's wonderful you're writing
stories about your friends.
Yes?
>> You know, sometimes
I write songs.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Ah!
That's another form of writing, song
writing, poetry writing, exactly.
Yes?
>> What was your very first book?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: My very
first book was another animal book.
And that was about -- called
Astro: The Stellar Sea Lion.
It's another true story, and
he was stranded, he was all --
left all alone as a little tiny pup.
And then they rescued him,
so that's a sweet story too.
Yes?
>> What person book
did you like -- ?
What kind of book do you like?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: What
kind of books do I like?
That's a good question.
I actually, oh, I like
so many types.
I just love to read,
but I like stories too,
the novels that have a good story
that I just can't stop reading.
And then I stay awake, and
I have to finish the book.
Do you ever read those?
>> Yeah.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah.
Yes?
>> What was your last person
book that you ever read?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: My last
-- oh, that I read, or wrote?
>> Or write.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Or wrote.
So, last person book.
So, do you know what the word --
what's a word called
for a person book?
Remember that?
Bio -- biography, right.
The last biography
I wrote it was an --
about an artist, and his
name was Romare Bearden.
And he painted big paintings,
and he lived in North Carolina,
then he went up to Harlem.
And he painted collages,
so lots about his family,
and it had trains in
it, he loved trains.
Because I also work at the Museum
of Modern Art in San Francisco.
And I give tours to students
there, and they had lots
of his paintings, and
I really liked that.
Maybe I can send your class
that book, I'll do that.
Yes?
>> Why did you write Mya Lin's book?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Why
did I write Mya Lin's book?
Great question.
Because I learned about her
back when I was in college
because she was in college.
And I just was always so
interested in her story,
so I wanted to learn more.
So, then I read books, and I went
to the Library of Congress website,
because I live all
the way in California.
But there's so much information that
I was able to find right on there,
but I like coming here in person.
Yes?
>> What do Mya -- What do Mya
Lin look like in person now?
>>Jean Walker Harvey: Oh,
that's a good question.
Oh, pretty much like the
photo, do you remember
when the cat was on the table?
That's pretty recent, right.
Yes?
>>What's your favorite painting?
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
What's my favorite painting?
Oh, that's impossible, that
-- but thank you for asking.
Oh, boy, I like so many artists
at the Museum of Modern Art.
So -- what's your favorite painting?
Do you have a favorite artist?
Do you do art?
>> Yeah.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Oh, good,
that might be a favorite
painting, yeah.
Let's see, who else -- ?
Yes?
>> Have you ever drew a painting?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Oh,
do I ever do a painting?
That's a good question,
because my mom
and my grandmother
were both artists.
And they made paint
-- I can't paint.
No, I'm not very good at that,
I'm more of a word person.
So, that's why I love
writing picture books so,
because I love the illustrations.
And didn't Dow do such beautiful
artwork, because both the words
and the pictures are equally
important, it's a collaboration.
I just love all your questions.
How much more time do we have?
Is this okay?
Great. Yes?
>> What's your favorite color?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Ooh, blue.
[ Laughter ]
>> Blue, yeah, that's my favorite.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
That's your -- yeah.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah.
Ooh, that's a nice
blue, really nice.
Yes?
>> Are you an illustrator
or an author?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: And --
so, if I write words, I'm a --
>> Author.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Author, excellent.
Yes. Yes?
>> What's your favorite
snack to eat?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Oh,
that's easy too, chocolate.
>> Ah!
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Now,
if they make blue chocolate,
think how happy I'd be.
>> Very happy.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Very happy.
>> What's your favorite number?
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Oh, I don't know, 23.
>> Twenty-three?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah.
Yes?
>> What's your favorite Doritos?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Doritos?
>> Chips?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Classic.
>> Classic?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Yeah.
Yes?
>> Why do you like books?
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
Why do I like books?
Oh, they open up a
world, new worlds for me.
I get to learn about other people,
other places, new experiences,
other ways of thinking,
new adventures.
Why do you like books?
What kind of books do you like?
Or what do like -- do you like
to read about animals or people?
Or all kinds?
>> All kinds.
>> Jean Walker Harvey:
All kinds, good.
Good. Yes?
>> Blue is my last name.
>> Jean Walker Harvey: What is?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Well, there
you go, Blue's your last name.
One more question, I don't
think I've heard from you.
Yes?
>> Do you ever read your own books?
>> Jean Walker Harvey: Do
I ever read my own books?
To you I do, I love that.
And you know, when I -- because I
write picture books that are meant
to be read aloud, I read
them aloud to my cat a lot.
So, she hears them all.
Thank you all so much for
being an amazing audience,
I just love seeing all of you.
So -- and thank you
for bringing them.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.